You just have to hear this completely ridiculous
turn of events in the Hunter Biden conspiracy
theory.
Tucker Carlson, Fox News host and propagandist,
now claims that he had obtained the absolutely
final devastating smoking gun documents that
would completely nail and destroy Hunter Biden
and by extension, Joe Biden.
But the documents were lost in the mail.
Could you believe that?
Check out Tucker Carlson explaining this.
Then I'll catch you up on the details of everything
that's going on here.
There's always a lot going on that we don't
have time to get to on the air.
But there is something specific going on behind
the scenes right now that we did feel we should
tell you about.
So on Monday of this week, we received from
a source a collection of confidential documents
related to the Biden family.
We believe those documents are authentic,
they're real, and they're damning.
At the time we received them.
My executive producer, Justin Wells and I
were in Los Angeles preparing to interview
Tony Baba Linsky about the Bidens business
dealings in China, Ukraine and other countries.
So we texted a producer in New York and we
asked him to send those documents to us in
L.A. and he did that.
So Monday afternoon of this week, he shipped
those documents overnight to California with
a large national carrier, brand name company
that we've used.
You've used countless times with never a single
problem.
But the Biden documents never arrived in Los
Angeles.
Tuesday morning, we received word from the
shipping company that our package had been
opened and the contents were missing.
The documents had disappeared.
Now, to its credit, the company took this
very seriously and immediately began a search.
They traced the envelope from the moment our
producers dropped it off in Manhattan on Monday
all the way to three forty four a.m. yesterday
morning.
That's when an employee at a sorting facility
in another state noticed that our package
was open and empty.
Apparently it had been open.
So the company's security team interviewed
every one of its employees who touched the
envelope we sent.
They searched the plane and the trucks that
carried it.
They went through the office in New York where
our producer drop that package off.
They comb the entire cavernous sorting facility.
They use pictures of what we had sent so that
searchers would know what to look for.
They went far and beyond, but they found nothing.
Those documents have vanished.
As of tonight, the company has no idea and
no working theory even about what happened
to this trove of materials, documents that
are directly relevant to the presidential
campaign.
Just six days from now, we spoke to executives
at that company a few hours ago.
They seemed baffled and deeply bothered by
this, and so are we.
There is just so much here.
And this is actually fascinating because the
disappearance of the supposed documents that
are supposedly damning has become part of
the conspiracy.
When he says a carrier.
You know, it could be USPS.
More likely he means FedEx or U.P.S..
My guess is if this had been USPS, he would
be very clear that it was the Postal Service.
So I assume this was U.P.S. or Federal Express.
The idea is the fact that the documents were
lost is part of the conspiracy to suppress
the information, but understand that every
aspect of this is completely indefeasible.
Here's a conspiracy theory.
Well, here are counterpoints, for example,
as were presented on Fox News a day ago to
Rudy Giuliani when interviewed on Fox Business.
Here's count.
Here's a counterpoint to what you're saying,
Rudy.
Your questions are part of the conspiracy
to suppress the story we are telling.
Well, there's really you can't you can't really
prove that that's not the case.
But there's no evidence for it.
We had documents and they were damning, but
they got lost.
And the fact that someone implicitly the idea
is someone took them, that's part of the proof
now that the documents were damning.
Except we can't show you the documents because
we don't really know.
Now, as a reminder, this is the conspiracy
theory about Hunter Biden that starts with
Hunter, who lives in California, flying across
the country to get three laptops fixed at
a repair shop run by a blind guy who says
because he's blind.
He didn't actually see Hunter Biden drop off
the laptops, but he believes it was Hunter
Biden, despite the fact that the person didn't
claim to be Hunter Biden because one of the
laptops had a sticker on it for the Beau Biden
Foundation, which is Hunter's late brother.
And for some reason, after flying across the
country to have his three laptops repaired,
it sounds like a comedy skit.
Hunter never picked the laptops up.
So the blind repair, who wasn't actually even
sure, who didn't actually see Hunter Biden,
but somehow believed that it was naturally
turned the laptops on Red Hunter Biden's private
emails and made copies of what was on the
hard drives and then sent the hard the laptops
to the FBI.
But the FBI, according to the repairman, didn't
do anything with the laptops.
So the repairman a while later said, I know
I'll call Rudy Giuliani and give him the material
I copied from the laptops.
That story where Hunter Biden for some reason
has three laptops repaired at a shop three
thousand miles from where he lives and then
never goes back and gets the laptops.
That's the genesis of this story now with
Tucker Carlson losing the documents.
Now, as far as the documents are concerned,
nobody makes a copy.
Nobody takes pictures of each page with a
cell phone.
You send the only copy you have across the
country with no backup.
What does Fox think?
That their viewers are this stupid where they're
now?
What the the dog ate my homework stage of
the conspiracy theory.
Honestly, guys, the proof was really damning,
but we lost it.
And you're just going to have to take our
word for it.
Does anybody also believe, by the way, that
FedEx or U.P.S., a major carrier, launched,
carried out, finished and reported on a full
investigation across multiple states in 24
hours?
Does anybody believe that?
Have you ever reported missing a book to FedEx
or U.P.S.?
Do you have any idea how long it takes to
do these investigations now?
Very important reminder here for everyone
thinking Tucker wouldn't lie about this in
defending Tucker Carlson in a lawsuit.
Fox News lawyers argued in September the things
Tucker says on his show should not be interpreted
as facts.
It is entertainment.
That's actually the defense Fox News lawyers
used in court in a lawsuit a month ago.
You can't literally believe.
The things Tucker says, because it's not it's
it's it looks like news, but it's merely entertainment.
So in truth, this entire story could be made
up because Tucker's show is entertainment.
It's amazing.
It's an amazing time we live in.